yeah welcome to this video playing fly
away from Armenia and kicks again yeah I
get a king's indian see six years just
affect the line age three i think is a
good good reply not leading to anything
great but i think this is one of the
battle lines d5 not sure the d5 is so
great iam really they play d 6 after h3
I know that c6 intensity five of course
hmm interesting okay let's not spend too
much time this is a bit strange what
he's doing isn't this is just just
magnificent center ok trying to
undermine it yeah ok this wasn't planned
beforehand this is just born out of all
of them that necessity yeah i'm just
getting before now with the big center
and extra porn
at least done this is what it looks like
I'm not far behind on the clock who came
so multiple ways to play Knight b6 SSI
is some his IDM and he's a ticking f5 I
could just take with the Queen no it's
probably both good but I don't don't
want to spend spend ages here
sir it's just a pawn okay so he six is
not great on the queen but he's placing
his queen directly into e6 which makes
our strange impression okay I want to
swear this over and just gamble that you
cannot take you five taking on d5 looks
really bad but maybe it sets bits it's
technically yeah he's just playing it
okay because of e-cigs I thought this
would be terrible maybe it's not it
takes with the Queen 95 wins instantly
and this just looks like yeah right out
of the cheese factory cannot cannot
really believe that this should should
be play one maybe it is okay can you
take it and what now 94-96 796 you can
take with the Queen and it's probably
not to win yeah just drop back him
ya know it was this wasn't the best I
mean I was just a pawn up for for
absolutely nothing and this might be
might be dangerous for him but it
doesn't look I'm completely winning
which white certainly was before yeah it
looks looks doesn't look nice but
somehow it's not it's not falling apart
95 s my dear but he can take F 2 mm
problem but if it takes an f2 I have
rope g470 dangerous it is it is it good
no idea let's do this first oh I'm
actually I'm actually I'm allowing him
to take ah why on earth did I do that ok
ok for I don't understand but I don't
understand anything here now this looks
looks excellent again
okay for Queen age five
or what what's now Queen a Quincy five
awesome some move maybe
I cannot also just take it with this urn
yeah but this is made into Jack Black
resign made 96 made king and checkmate
mate yeah this is preston the result
fits the position after move from 14 but
in the yeah he was very very okay of
course i just played this battling like
it's me yeah so is the desire to to
really punish the other guy for it's a
terrible play and you you should still
try to to play good moves the Sun yeah
maybe it is it's just not great it looks
it looks nice quite quite active but
probably it's not not really great he's
got all this holds here but this is just
good its controls f4 gets this into the
game it's probably compensation but not
a big edge for might get this is you can
just take here this is completely a
mysterious why I didn't do something
like that this is so again again quite
nice for Hawaii here and here i thought
i thought this one trying to get some
counter play maybe rookie too
complicated and hard to assess and this
is don't think this is playable now
again you should play Quincy five yeah
this is lost now I cannot cannot prevent
that yeah the real issue was that I
simply should play here and all move
books e14
Luke c5 it's just just enormous the
center I shouldn't try to to meet him
quickly okay thanks for watching